the field of candidates planning to take
on Joe Biden in 2024 has just doubled
yesterday a week after president Trump
announced that he would seek re-election
Kanye West announced that he too will be
running for president
oh yeah
so you are running
thank you
yes that's awesome simple as that
you know yeah she's saying this you
should say that you know
you know it's just we're moving towards
the future
like so what we do here is I'll cut up
you know a hundred hoodies from Yeezy
from Balenciaga from the stuff we did at
Gaff and stuff we did Adidas and
everything we do is gonna cost twenty
dollars we need to make sure that
everyone can receive the same level of
cuts the same level of food same amount
of the water same level of Education the
curriculum the engineering where beings
with engineering opportunities we're
getting past the past we're focused on
the future
focused on the future some people are
making fun of yay's somewhat digressive
campaign announcement but he is
certainly no less coherent than the
current occupant of the Oval Office
another potentially disqualifying Factor
would be his recent nasty comments on
Race particularly with regard to the
Jews but then on that front Kanye hasn't
said anything more racially offensive
than say Joe Biden or Richard Nixon or
LBJ or Woodrow Wilson the list goes on
and on no
racist or anti-semitic comments would
not especially distinguish Kanye from
past presidents and presidential
candidates what does distinguish him
from past presidential candidates and
what connects him with the only other
Challenger candidate in the field right
now
is something much stranger
Kanye West like Donald Trump is
currently and consistently banned from
large parts of the social media that is
from the Public Square
they've recently had their Twitter
access restored but they are both still
banned from Instagram
Trump is banned from pretty much all of
social media we're currently living in a
country in which the entire field of the
sitting presidents declared opponents
are being largely censored out of the
Public Square the very heart of
self-government we've never seen
anything like that before
whatever you think of Donald Trump or
Kanye West that poses a far more direct
threat to our Republic than whatever
either of them have to say I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Crystal Parker
who says it is so very obvious that Tia
oh this is that actress lady was
attempting to explain away her marriage
failure I was thinking the whole time
was she trying to convince me or herself
seems to me she just felt like she
needed to explain it all away and make
it okay somehow uh would have been much
better to just admit failure since we
all fail and sin from time to time
that's so true and and it's something
that in our culture which largely views
itself as post-christian which rejects
the the wisdom and truth of Christianity
we we can't acknowledge when we sin and
then repent and seek forgiveness we've
everything's got to be perfect oh it's
good oh no it's really I'm really glad
that I got divorced oh I'm really glad
that I did a ton of drugs oh I'm really
glad that I screwed up my whole life no
it's really good that I did that
actually actually when you really think
about it those are all wonderful things
no you don't need to pretend we all know
that isn't true you're obviously just
trying to convince your yourself you can
admit it you can say I screwed up I
messed up and it was bad and I messed
things up for a lot of other people too
I'm sorry please God forgive me you can
say that but it's very difficult to say
that in a culture that no longer
believes in God because then then you
don't get forgiveness and then you go
crazy as our culture has
when we when we get a little bit crazy I
I especially in the morning when I wake
up I feel very very crazy I need to
focus when I want to focus I turn to
Black Rifle coffee right now head on
over to Black riflecoffee.com use promo
code Knowles do you have a coffee lover
on your holiday shopping list Black
Rifle coffee has all the best Brewing
gear thermoses mugs and apparel designed
for folks who love country and coffee
Black Rifle sources the most exotic
roasts from around the globe all coffee
is roasted here in the US by veteran-led
teams of coffee experts stuff your
Christmas stockings with the latest
roasts from America's coffee for 10 off
with my promo code Knowles better yet
sign up your Secret Santa for a coffee
Club subscription imagine the joy of a
pre-scheduled coffee delivery your
favorite roasts when you need them most
it's the gift that keeps on giving Black
Rifle coffee company is veteran founded
and operated they take pride in serving
coffee and culture to people who love
America every purchase you make with
Black Rifle helps support veteran and
first responder causes
go to Black riflecoffee.com use promo
code notes for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear
apparel or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription that is black
riflecoffee.com promo code Knowles for
10 off Black Rifle coffee supporting
veterans and America's coffee
speaking of Kanye you heard there in his
sort of Meandering campaign announcement
Kanye referred to Balenciaga Balenciaga
is a very high-end luxury fashion house
and
Kanye had a deal with Balenciaga and
Balenciaga has weird imagery for a long
time I mean one of their runway fashion
shows was in a bunch of mud and dirt
black and it all looked kind of demonic
and it's it's weird to begin with well
they just put out some ads
that are that are more disturbing than
anything that I had ever seen from them
it's this ad it was right on their
website
of these two little girls
very little girls standing on a bed or
on a sofa
surrounded by some valenciaga products
holding little stuffed animals that are
wearing weird sex gear like weird S M
Leather chains harnesses all that kind
of stuff
and so that in and of itself is very
disturbing you say why are these and the
kids don't look particularly happy we
blurt out their faces but the look on
their face on the website not very happy
they say why are these kids holding this
weird
not just sexual symbol but actually
sadistic sexual symbol a kind of sexual
symbol that involves pain that seems uh
really really weird but then if you zoom
in
you can see that there are some weird
papers underneath the Balenciaga handbag
and some other other uh items that
they're selling and if you really zoom
in on one of them you can see uh
speech Coalition is just a line of text
and it refers to sexual depiction and
but some of it's covered up it's hard to
read so
if you look up the the text if you just
pull out some of the fragments of the
sentences
you see that the case that this comes
from is United States versus Williams
this is a Supreme Court case from 2008
and it was a decision by the Supreme
Court that a federal statute prohibiting
the pandering of child pornography
did not violate the First Amendment so
I guess that's good I mean this was a
good decision that said yeah you you can
ban people from not peddling Kitty porn
and that that doesn't violate their
first amendment up but it it is just
weird that the Balenciaga company is not
only putting kids in these weird
sexual associations but then referring
to child pornography not all that subtly
in the advertisement and then the case
that is referred to within that case
United States versus Williams is a case
called Ashcroft versus Free Speech
Coalition which was a case that that
determined whether or not simulated
child pornography was protected by the
First Amendment and the Supreme Court
wrongly concluded that simulated child
porn
was in fact protected by the First
Amendment so we're not talking about
child pornography of actual kids being
exploited but you know cartoons or very
highly developed renderings that look
just like kids but they're not actually
real kids that that that kind of porn is
protected which is really really
disturbing
so now how do we read this it's kind of
a kind of a strange juxtaposition here
because you've got one case that was so
wrongly decided that advances child
pornography you've got the other case
which is the actual text that's there
underneath the the bag that suppresses
child pornography and then you've got
these kids with these weird sexual
associations it's just
ah I don't know I feel like a conspiracy
theorist even bringing this up but then
what have we learned over the past three
years at least
the difference between a conspiracy
theory and the truth is about three to
six months and we've heard little
murmurs of weird child porn child sex
stuff throughout the culture and they're
always pooh-pooed as a sort of crazy
conspiracy theory there you go you
radical right-wingers with your tin foil
hats again
I don't want to hear that okay
obviously the weird kids sex stuff is
happening that's not a crazy conspiracy
theory we know it's happening
we uncovered one of the biggest child
sex rings in the world that was called
Jeffrey Epstein and his creepy pedo
Island that was all real and it involved
some of the most famous wealthy powerful
people on planet Earth who took dozens
of trips on the Lolita Express Jeffrey
Epstein paddling around with royalty
with major CEOs blackmail compromat
Galore when Jeffrey Epstein was first
prosecuted for this according to then
U.S attorney then future nominee for
labor secretary Alex Acosta Acosta was
told don't don't deal with Epstein
Epstein belongs to intelligence okay so
obviously this stuff is real and I don't
want to hear it okay
I don't want to hear oh you guys you're
looking too much into this Balenciaga ad
it's just a it's a totally harmless
image of a little kid looking sad
holding an s m teddy bear
standing on top of a Supreme Court case
about child pornography I don't want to
hear it it's all of that stuff is real
okay and and right now if you present to
me CNN
and Alex Jones or whoever insert radical
crazy new conspiracy there's right
winger
I am going to be much more inclined to
believe the latter the latter have a
much better record and the former are
are not only dishonest and frequently
wrong in their stories but they're
shills for the power structure that is
so obviously corrupt and so obviously
creepy and weird explain explain that ad
to me explain that ad to me
in the world in which we know that the
creepypeto island is real
explain that ad to me as something
totally innocent I I just don't see how
you could speaking of conspiracy
theories we found out another conspiracy
theory is real CBS News take it away
as Republicans take control of the house
Hunter Biden the president's son will be
a target for investigations and that
means data from a laptop reported to
belong to Biden could be crucial to the
investigatory process CBS News has
obtained its data not through a third
party or political operative but
directly from the source who told us
they provided it to the FBI under
subpoena and we commissioned an
independent forensic review to determine
its authenticity senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Harris joins us
now with what we found Catherine I'm
very interested good morning Good
morning Tony the laptop data we had
analyzed showed no evidence it was faked
or tampered with you're confident based
on your analysis this is Hunter Biden's
data and that it's real yes wow breaking
news from CBS telling us something that
every sensible person has known for two
years
but two years ago we weren't allowed to
talk about that we actually weren't
allowed to talk about it even on social
media not even just publicly post you
weren't allowed to privately message
a New York Post article about Hunter
Biden's laptop because the entire power
structure clamped down on it and said no
this is disinformation it wasn't was
completely true and now cbs's breaking
news our independent forensic
investigators have proven
oh you couldn't could you guys not have
hired those independent forensic
investigators
sometime over the past two years maybe
during the presidential campaign or even
like six months later or six months
after that or six months after that or
no just now just now that Hunter Biden
is about to be investigated and it's all
over and the Republicans retook the
house now is exactly the time it's so
transparent what they're doing
and it just
they're they're doing it to save face
because when it's obviously the case
that the hunter Biden laptop is real
which we all already know then they'll
be able to say no we ran this report
we're the serious news people it's so
transparent what they're doing these
guys are liars and hacks and
propagandists and they're covering up
for very bad people doing very bad
things and there is no reason to take a
word that they have to say seriously a
random right-wing lunatic broadcasting
from his RV on a shortwave radio has
more journalistic credibility and a
higher standard of Ethics than CBS News
and all the rest of the establishment
media speaking of conspiracy theorists
the race for a Democrat minority leader
in the house is on you know Nancy Pelosi
has lost her gavel she's no longer the
speaker she's not interested in being
the Democrat minority leader in the
house so she's out now someone someone's
got to replace her the leading candidate
to replace her is this guy Hakeem
Jeffries Hakeem Jeffries is a radical
left-winger if the name Jeffries sounds
familiar it's because his uncle uh
Professor Jeffries was a CUNY Professor
who popularized the idea that white
people or the people of the ice and
black people are the people of the sun
and the white people are intrinsically
evil and the black people are
intrinsically good and the the white
people don't really have souls and you
remember all that stuff that Nick Cannon
was talking about a few years ago how
the the white people are like animals
and dogs and just evil evil people and
then the the the black people are the
only good people well that comes from
Hakeem Jeff freezes uncle
who was allowed to get away with this
for years and years and years eventually
he sort of strayed into the anti-semitic
territory as well and so he really kind
of broadened his attacks and eventually
he went down I mean that that kind of
took him down but he was allowed to
spread his bile and filth for a very
long time the whole I I don't mean to
imply guilt by association here for
Hakeem Jeffries but when we hear Hakeem
Jeffries say radical leftist things it's
important to know the context this guy
comes from an extremely radical somewhat
prominent family especially in New York
and so Hakeem Jeffries has peddled the
most left-wing kind of wacky theories
including that the 2016 election was
illegitimate take a listen
there's a cloud of illegitimacy hanging
over the white house right now Russia
interfered with our election for the
exclusive purpose of trying to
artificially Place Donald Trump at 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue he wants to continue
to play footsie with Vladimir Putin
Donald Trump's going to continue to
stand for Vladimir Putin and that's
shameful they are under criminal
investigation in terms of the Trump
campaign's possible role in colluding
with Russian spies to attack on
Democracy it seems that the Trump
campaign conspired with Russian spies to
sell out our democracy and now you have
members closely affiliated with the
Trump Administration and possibly the
president who are engaged in the
cover-up 17 different intelligence
agencies have concluded that Russia
interfered with our election attacked
our democracy for the sole purpose of
artificially placing someone at 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue
artificially placing Trump is an
artificial president Trump is an
illegitimate president what does that
sound like to you
it sounds like
election denial he's deny he's a denier
of the election oh my gosh he's like the
January six people except he's not
yes
it is a little bit awkward and a little
bit hypocritical
to think that the Democrats who have
spent the last two years
screaming until they're blue in the face
about the evils of election denial and
the threat that that poses to our sacred
democracy and how if you ever question
the results of an election you're evil
you're a terrorist you need to be cast
into the outer Darkness it is a little
bit awkward if those Democrats now make
an election denier
their leader
but it won't matter I'm telling you now
it won't matter
and Republicans are are probably not
going to figure it out until it's too
late we're going to waste a lot of time
shouting look at the hypocrisy look if
the shoe were on the other foot look can
you imagine if the roles were reversed
they don't care they don't care they
agree with Hakeem Jeffries they do think
the 2016 election was illegitimate
whether Vladimir Putin did anything or
not the libs believe that anytime the
Republicans win an election that that is
illegitimate that it was either the
result of some fraud or even more
broadly it was the result of the
misinformation that has lulled people
into a false consciousness to vote
against their interests because no
sensible person would ever vote for a
republican so that's that's what they
believe and so anytime the Democrats win
that's legit anytime the Republicans win
that is not legit
to quote Adrian vermeul the great
Harvard law professor as I quote him
frequently it's not hypocrisy it's
hierarchy
just they get to play by a different set
of rules okay and so it won't matter
it's like when Republicans say well
Democrats are the real racists right
Democrats accuse us of being racists and
then the Republican response is no
you're the racists
that's never going to work because
by definition according to the left the
Republicans are racists and they're
always racists and the Democrats are not
racists and can never be racists racism
according to the Democrats is whenever
someone does something that the
Democrats don't like that's racism
I will never forget when a liberal
caller to a talk radio show
coincidentally hosted by David Webb was
disagreeing with him over something I
don't even remember what the issue was
and she said on the radio well David you
only say that because of your white
privilege and this was very funny
because David Webb for those of you who
know him is very much a black man he is
not a white man but this was radio and
the caller couldn't see him and she just
went to that she just goes to that
because that's just what the Democrats
go to whenever you disagree with them
you are a racist you're a white
supremacist you have white privilege and
so it won't matter
and it is a Fool's errand to to retort
and say well no you're you're the real
racist they don't care about that they
just care about beating you
okay they don't care about election
denial of course they don't they're the
ones who deny the elections going at
least back to the year 2000 and they've
denied elections a hell of a lot more
than Republicans have and with far less
reason than Republicans have had they
just want to beat you and so you can say
no but don't you see the hypocrisy yeah
maybe they do but they don't care okay
they don't they just don't view it that
way
which is why we need to win
we need to stop trying to convince them
of their own hypocrisy about which they
do not care we just have to win okay and
so you're seeing a major fight play out
in the Senate right now and very few
people are talking about it
the Liberals aren't talking about it
because they think they've got the fight
in the bag and the Republicans aren't
talking about it because they're
absolute cowards and moral idiots but we
need to focus on this this is a very
important fight it's over the
redefinition of marriage and the Not
only uh destruction of of the
institution of marriage but the
obliteration of religious liberty from
American public life and this is through
something called the respect for
Marriage Act
most Preposterous euphemism we've ever
had in American law and what the respect
for Marriage Act does is it not only
enshrines the legal definition of
marriage from obergefell which is
preposterous
but it actually goes much further than
that and it prevents lots and lots of
Americans from objecting in any
significant way to that radical
redefinition of marriage so if you
believe as do uh Christians and Jews and
Muslims and sensible people uh
throughout all of history until five
minutes ago if you believe as did Barack
Obama in 2011 well into his first term
that marriage is an institution between
a man and a woman the sexual difference
has something to do with marriage then
you're basically booted from public life
at this point if you express that in any
significant way if this law passes it's
a disaster and a dozen squish morally
vacuous Republicans and intellectually
vacuous Republicans voted for this thing
so they voted to get past the filibuster
which means now it's on a fast track to
get a vote we can still hold this thing
up a little bit
we're not going to defeat the bill the
bill is going to pass but what Mike Lee
the great senator from Utah who came
pretty close to losing his re-election
bid and we had him on this show because
it was just awful to think that Mike Lee
was not going to win re-election well
Mike Lee coming to the rescue here with
the Lee amendment to give protections
for Christians and Jews and Muslims and
sensible agnostics and atheists too uh
to to be able to express the real
meaning of marriage without facing
punishment from the federal government
in the Public Square okay and we'll get
into what that that Amendment does
because it should help you rest a little
bit easier at night if we can get it
through and when when you want to rest
easy every single night you've got to
get bowling Branch sheets right now go
to bowlingbranch.com use promo code
Michael Christmas is approaching if you
want to enjoy Christmas and New Year's
and Thanksgiving and all the holidays to
the fullest you need to get your best
sleep it is easier than it sounds all
you need is the most soft luxurious
organic cotton bed sheets that you've
ever seen from Bowling Branch bowl and
Branch sheets are made from the finest
100 organic cotton threads on Earth in
fact their signature hemmed sheets were
made with threads so luxurious that
three U.S presidents and one of your
favorite podcasters have slept in them
bowling Branch sheets are made free from
toxins pesticides and other harsh
chemicals they actually soften with
every wash cycle they come in nine
neutral colors all mattress sizes their
signature sheets come wrapped in a
beautiful holiday gift box who wouldn't
love the gift of a good night's sleep
this year best of all bowling Branch
gives you a 30 night risk-free trial
with free shipping and Returns on all
orders but you will not want to return
them you will love them they are
absolutely fabulous this season give the
gift of a better night's sleep with bowl
and branch right now I get 25 off your
first set of sheets plus free shipping
when you use promo code Michael at
bowlingbranch.com that's bowling branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
Michael hurry this special Black Friday
offer ends November 27th Mike Lee coming
to the rescue here
to insert this amendment into the the
new redefining marriage bill in the
Senate why does this matter a lot of
conservatives write in they say you know
Michael I'm with you on a lot of things
but I just don't care about this
marriage stuff if the gays want to get
married and be as miserable as the rest
of us you know who cares that's fine by
me and haha yes I know we all tell that
joke it's a little bit glib but I get it
it's a kind of funny Barb however it
obviously matters
it obviously matters because marriage is
the fundamental political institution
it's the building block of all of
Politics the libs think and want for the
building block of politics to just be
the individual because it's much easier
to dominate individuals when they're
atomized and broken up from
intermediating institutions most notably
the family the conservatives understand
that the family is key and the family is
not just some socially constructed
institution where we can say okay we're
going to make a polycule with three
girls and two guys and a goat and that's
going to be the new definition of a
family no marriage is not socially
constructed it is a there are social
aspects to it and and
intellectualized and ritualized aspects
to it but it is a natural institution as
Aristotle observed as St Thomas Aquinas
observed as smart people throughout all
of human history have observed because
man is naturally a pairing being we are
drawn to our the complementarity of the
Sexes and by the complementarity of the
Sexes and within that unit of one man
and one woman
there is the possibility of life and
marriage is instituted for the good of
the spouses and the sake of the
generation and the education of children
okay that is what the thing is for and
and so if you find yourself in a
position where you say well who I just
don't care I just don't see what the big
deal is then maybe ask yourself
why don't you see what the big deal is
maybe just take a step back and say you
know with a little bit of humility here
this institution
has been viewed for all of human history
by all the smartest people and pretty
much everyone else too as extremely
important
and it still remains viewed as extremely
important by the liberal activists who
are trying to radically redefine him and
actually the only people ever in the
history of the world who don't think
this thing matters
is just like me and some of my Live and
Let Live kind of laissez-faire
libertarian friends why is that
maybe maybe
you're missing something here maybe a
lot of people are missing something here
as to why this thing has been viewed is
so important by pretty much everybody
ever so what the what the Lee Amendment
proposes
is based on an Infamous exchange from
the obergefell decision that redefined
marriage
and it was when Sam Alito conservative
judge asked whether religious
universities that were opposed to
same-sex marriage would lose their
tax-exempt status if marriage were
redefined at the federal level
and varilli speaking for the government
said it's certainly going to be an issue
I don't deny that I don't deny that
Justice Alito it is going to be an issue
so Mike Lee writes it is an issue a
burgerfeld did not make a private right
of action for aggrieved individuals to
sue those who oppose same-sex marriage
it did not create a mandate for the
Department of Justice to sue where it
perceived an institution opposed
same-sex marriage but the respect for
Marriage Act will this radical bill that
the libs are pushing through that the
squish Republicans are are going along
with what we can expect
should this bill become law is more
litigation against those institutions
and individuals trying to live according
to their sincerely held religious
beliefs and moral convictions and even
most absurdly the people who are going
to be on the back foot here and who are
going to have to constantly defend
themselves against lawsuits are going to
be the people with sincerely held
religious beliefs and moral convictions
that are correct
they're not just sincerely held they're
true and they're going to be the ones
who are going to be destroyed by this
we're all going to be Jack Phillips
we're all going to be masterpiece cake
shop it will obliterate any defense of
what is now
called traditional marriage it's also
known as marriage it's going to
obliterate what remains of that defense
from the Public Square I urge you call
your Congressman call your senators
tell them to vote against this bill
at least until the Lee amendment is
adopted it might be a largely lost cause
for the moment
to defeat the bill entirely which we
should do we can I think still get the
Lee Amendment through call your Senator
especially if your Senator is one of the
Dozen squishes who voted uh to over
override the filibuster and get this
thing on a fast track call your Center
and tell them to stop this nonsense
speaking of LGBT politics
LGBT politics identity politics is
everywhere these days including the head
of FIFA including the head of the
international soccer organization who
who made this
odd declaration the other day
today I feel uh gay
I don't I don't have much commentary for
that uh I think that's just the whole
quote the head of international soccer
says
I feel
gay
there it is it's everywhere that
identity that identity is every even at
the World Cup in Qatar okay that's very
much in the Zeitgeist it's very much in
the spirit of the age
we need to make sure though that these
sorts of political Fashions do not uh
do not go so far as to destroy the
institutions in building blocks of
society speaking of the Middle East
I don't know if you heard I don't know
if you've heard about the biggest most
important news story ever according to
the liberal establishment media
Joe Biden
is not going to destroy U.S Saudi
relations at a time of a major energy
crisis where we are reliant on
cooperation with Saudi Arabia not to
plunge the world even further into
recession
Biden is not going to throw all that
away
over the killing of Jamal khashoggi
do you remember Jamal khashoggi
Jamal khashoggi
well I won't tell you
I'll just tell you what the Washington
Post and the liberal media say about
Jamal khashoggi Jamal khashoggi is a was
a Washington Post columnist he was a
journalist who was targeted by the evil
Saudi regime and murdered
because he stood up for journalism and
the Intrepid Free Press and Joe Biden is
letting this man get away with murder
okay and that's basically the gist of
the statement issued by the Washington
Post now the problem with that narrative
is is it isn't true
or it's got a little kernel of truth
that gives it credibility but it it's
that kernel of Truth is stretched in
such a way that it it hides the reality
of this man I'm not defending the Saudis
killing this guy Jamal khashoggi but
what I am telling you is they didn't
kill a Washington Post columnist Jamal
khashoggi was a career political
operative and spy for Saudi Arabia who
was on the outs with the now dominant
part of the Saudi royal family Jamal
khashoggi was Palling around with Osama
Bin Laden decades ago okay Jamal
khashoggi is not some columnist yes he
wrote some columns
we've all written some columns okay
the column thing the the writing for the
Washington posting was a cover for his
actual job which is that he was a
political operative in a very dangerous
part of the world every dangerous
Kingdom doing very dangerous stuff
including Espionage and he wound up
being assassinated by a rival political
power
it's ugly it's an ugly business
but this is not a man bites dog story
here okay this sort of thing happens all
the time in the world of power politics
and Espionage okay and what's really
interesting about the story is not that
the Saudi regime killed a dissident that
happens all the time
what's interesting about the story is
not that a political power has gone
after and punished dissidents that
happens all the time too that happens in
every regime ever
what's really interesting here is the
way that the media
were able to spin up this whole
narrative to get people to to to pull
their hair out to rent their garments
over Jamal khashoggi if you were one of
the people
they got really worked up over Jamal
khashodi
Aya did you ever say why this guy I had
never heard of before
all of a sudden I am meant to really
really
feel for and I am and I'm very I'm
feeling very emotional over this person
and it's actually happening it's not
only that the Washington Post wants me
to feel that way I am feeling that way
you ever ask yourself why maybe that
you're being manipulated
you see this with every current thing
whatever the current thing is people
just
get wrapped up in it the war in Ukraine
Warren Ukraine is a very sad thing war
is a very sad thing there are lots of
Wars going on all over the world right
now why the war in Ukraine why did
everyone change their picture on Twitter
to be the Ukrainian flag
why why are you who you I'm not saying
you if you're listening to this show
you're probably more knowledgeable about
politics that 99.5 of people in the
world but for for the people who just
changed their flag who don't really pay
very close attention to this stuff
these people I promise you don't know
anything about Ukraine they don't know
anything about Russia they don't know
anything about the Millennium long
conflict in that region they don't know
anything about the stakes of the war
they don't know anything about the 2014
Revolution my Dawn Revolution they don't
know anything about International
participation in Ukrainian politics they
don't know anything about the expansion
of NATO they don't know they don't know
anything about anything okay but they're
just they're just convinced they get
wrapped up in that and then a week later
they're gone they forget about Ukraine
okay remember net neutrality remember
when we were all going to die from net
neutrality people actually said
prominent blue check people said if net
neutrality goes through people will die
most people don't even know what net
neutrality is
but net neutrality was was repealed it
was had been instituted it was repealed
and no one died
it was okay you remember Kony 2012
many of you are probably too young to
remember there was the social media
phenomenon koni 2012 everyone changed
their their pictures on Facebook we're
gonna get Coney who's Coney some random
guy running around Africa doing all
sorts of bad things but no one he's just
some minor warlord but he just he became
the current thing whenever one of these
causes happens these sort of cause celeb
these cause du jour I don't know why I'm
speaking French so much but they have a
lot of phrases for the the thing that
I'm describing when this stuff pops up
the current thing
before you change your Twitter picture
before you let your blood pressure go up
the first thing you got to ask yourself
why am I being made to care about this
by whom and for what purpose you know
the new daily wire plus story is live
and it is your One-Stop shop for all the
gifts worth giving because the fact is
nobody wants a bag of meal worm trail
mix or a tailored suit lightly worn by
Klaus Schwab okay
it's just not what's hot right now
go to dailywire.com shop
you got to pick up yes or no yes or no
baby that is my board game that is the
Michael Knowles board game that your
whole family will love
you can also get copies of my number one
National best-selling book speechless
controlling words controlling mines that
is my do we have the Bell still no
there's no Bell what the heck uh that
would be my book with words you can of
course also get my don't squish t-shirt
talking about them squishes all year you
can you can get that backbone up there
you know hold the line and for those who
do you have you have earned the right to
wear that don't squish t-shirt shipping
is free on orders over 75 bucks with
orders over 100 you get a free leftist
tears Tumblr great great time to go
shopping right now
skip the Cyber woke this holiday pick up
gifts made exclusively from truth go to
dailywire.com shop today
speaking of things not to care about
on the order of net neutrality
the uh
Jamal khashoggi Affair all the things to
really worry yourself about
there's another one to add to the list
Michelle Obama
is complaining
not exactly a major breaking news
headline Michelle Obama does nothing but
complain
but Michelle Obama is complaining this
time about how
when her husband was elected president
Americans were not ready
for her natural hair
I don't know what Michelle Obama's
natural hair looks like I I truly
couldn't possibly care less what
Michelle Obama's natural hair looks like
Michelle Obama was giving an interview
to Ellen DeGeneres
this was reported by the independent we
don't have a clip of it but we do have
the quote
she said let me keep my hair straight
let's get health care passed first they
tripped out when Barack wore a tan suit
you know the great indignity the scandal
of the Obama Administration this one
Barack wore a tan suit
so there everyone was on edge to
criticize Obama and she just said I
don't know if I can wear my natural hair
the code of ethics at a workplace as
black women we deal with it the whole
thing about do you show up with your
natural hair I would get my staff all
worried too I was like I was thinking
about getting braids that's the
African-American experience but women in
offices that are worried should I wear
skirts should I wear pantyhose I hate
pantyhose but when you're carrying all
this other stuff this mask
these differences and you're trying to
do your job it's just an extra burden
on overcoming
so I'm going to get that out now you
know I know some people like it when I
play ukulele
or sometimes guitar home so I'm just
going to pull out
and there it is
the world's tiniest little Stradivarius
violin just
there we go just play that out for
burdens of Michelle Obama to overcome
the completely
absurdly perceived stigma again about
how she wears her hair
the people of the United States
had just elected her husband
Barack Hussein Obama
to be the president of the United States
we had been at War
against at least initially a man named
Hussein for uh
five years at that point
and really actually much longer U.S
policy against Saddam Hussein Gourmet
the early 90s and
we are told that with the American
people just we're not ready for it was
Michelle Obama's here Barack Obama wore
his natural hair by the way first black
president
no it was but it's all about Michelle
and it's all America elected the first
black president but no there's still
evil and racist the American people they
gave Michelle Obama an absolute fairy
tale life no they're still it's so awful
for her it's so terrible this is the
burden of overcoming this is what black
people this is what makes their lives so
difficult you know do you show up with
natural hair now
I defer to the black listeners of this
show
is that that's the biggest problem in
your life
how to wear your what hairstyle to have
at the office I bet not
I bet not when I think about
long conversations with my black friends
I they don't usually bring up how to
wear their hair as the biggest challenge
they have real problems Michelle Obama
doesn't have any real problems and so
she has to make up problems because
the Obamas like the libs broadly
cannot take a yes for an answer
they can't take yes for an answer
it's there's always got to be a problem
there racism will never go away it can't
go away
according to the libs because that's
that's the premise they're starting from
they need it
okay oppression
suffering
all these things look evil never never
will go away not until not during this
period of earth right not until the
second coming we're not we're not going
to say this is a Fallen World okay so
there's always going to be evil and
suffering and the good way to react to
evil and suffering is with a spirit of
resignation and uh with virtue and so
that you can allow suffering to sanctify
you this was a line I think was from
Saint Jose Maria escriva who said never
say that person annoys me say oh that
person sanctifies me
we're all going to be going at
Thanksgiving to visit our family maybe
you've got a difficult family maybe you
got some you know sibling or cousin or
in-law or something that drives you
crazy no you that person doesn't annoy
you that person sanctifies you
and if you cultivate that attitude I
promise you it doesn't matter how
terrible
the the suffering is
you will be buoyant we talked about this
earlier I guess it was last week with
Jay Leno Jay Leno just suffered horrible
Burns but he's buoyant he bounced right
back he was giving out cookies to the
kids in the in the hospital he was he
was being treated at okay if you
cultivate those virtues
no no amount of suffering is going to
keep you down for very long
if you don't if all you do is cultivate
resentment and envy and anger and all
the stuff that Michelle Obama does
then no amount of privilege will ever
make you feel happy you can be the first
lady of the United States and you will
still be angry about how you in your
fantasies your hair might be perceived
okay there is no limit to the things
that you will complain about
you if you cultivate those things we get
you know hap Vice and virtue are habits
okay and you and you get what you do and
what you cultivate now
speaking of vices queen of all vices
pride and there's a very strange claim
made on The View yesterday this is by
Sunny Hosten
who she's kind of the B team of the view
she's not Whoopi she's not Joy Behar but
she's one of the libs on well they're
all Libs on you but she's she's one of
the more eccentric ones and and she made
a theological claim that
I'm no trained Theologian but it left me
scratching my head they were in a place
that accepts them for who they were and
someone came to that place I don't know
that they hide behind religion because I
said this on this show once before Jesus
would be the Grand Marshal at the pride
parade I don't mean about gay people I
mean in every argument we have but
here's your weaponized religion but it's
wrong if you're so afraid why are you
going over there yeah if they scare you
so much leave them alone
Jesus would be the Grand Marshal of the
pride parade
what does that even mean
I get in a sense Christ is King of the
universe and so he's Grand Marshal of
all of creation and I guess there are
Pride parades in some places in creation
but what is that I don't think that's
what she's referring to what does that
mean Jesus would be the Grand Marshal of
the pride parade this is something that
the libs do all the time when it comes
to religion
and it's totally incoherent but what
they will say is
they'll say explicitly or implicitly at
least they'll say look I think
Christianity is dumb and stupid and
wrong and backward and dated and just
complete nonsense and all you people are
Lemmings and fools and idiots for
following the teachings of Christianity
hey Christianity is done I don't believe
in that I don't believe in any of that
stuff you know I mean I don't believe in
God I'm just you know I'm just going to
do me man and I'm just so much smarter
than everybody and I'm a really Smart
Genius atheist with a fedora that I tip
but also I'm much more Christian you
don't even understand Christianity you
know this is ridiculous
ridiculous line from people who I
promise you have not even a passing
familiarity with the religion it's it's
this phenomenon of oh this is the worst
one they'll say you'll hear from Libs
sometimes they'll say listen I went to
Catholic school for 10 years
and uh so I'm I'm basically I'm
basically Saint Augustine you know I'm
I'm basically Thomas Aquinas all right
because I briefly went to a Catholic
High School so and I'm a complete
apostate and Fallen away from the faith
but let me tell you about your religion
right that's what they that's what they
all do and what is the why do they do it
they do it because they reject religion
as
an intellectual matter
but they recognize at least
subconsciously that man is a religious
being and so they have to make religious
arguments they recognize the strength of
religion even in their own lives even in
how it pulls on them and so what they do
is they align their view they claim that
their views are the views of God
what Christians do
what religious people do is that they
you using their moral conscious and
their faculties of reason and their
respect for tradition and their reading
of the scripture and their participation
in the Liturgy they ascertain what God
wants yes they can
and then when their behavior doesn't
jive with what God wants they change
their behavior and attempt to change
their behavior and repent which means to
change your mind and to bring their
views and behaviors into line with what
God wants what the libs do is exactly
the opposite
when they realize that there's a huge
Gulf between what God wants as stated in
the scripture in the sacred tradition as
perceived by our moral conscience
and our reason
a gulf between that and their own
behavior
they tried to conquer
God's will they say my will is God's
will they try to make of themselves gods
they do what the serpent tells even the
Garden of Eden he it he they they say
that we shall be as gods and this is
what Whitaker chamber said is the very
heart of of Communism is is man making
themselves Gods it's the heart of
radical leftism
that is all they're going to do well if
you've got to live in a world in which
God is the Grand Marshal in which Christ
is the Grand Marshal
or the world in which Sunny Hosten is
the Grand Marshal which are you going to
pick you got to pick one the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss this okay if you are not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
[Music]